kiev est toujours menacée d'encerclement
une autre grande ville d'ukraine l'êtes
aussi odessa grand port sur la mer noire
le dernier grand ver ou terrestre avant
odessa s'appelle nicolas yves à 130km
bombardé intensément ces derniers jours
sur place on retrouve notre envoyé
spécial julie d'une gueule of july
bonjour vous venez de faire la route
d'odessa jusqu'à nicolas yves une route
truffée de checkpoint
oui une route truffée de checkpoint vous
l'avez dit damien ce sont 130 kilomètres
que nous avons parcouru de nombreux
checkpoints sur la route ou bien les
militaires ukrainien vérifie bien sûr
notre identité vérifiez également que
nous avons toutes les autorisations pour
pénétrer dans cette ville et pour
arriver bien dans le centre ville de
nicolet où je me trouve eh bien il faut
traverser un pont et bien ce pont tout
autour de ce pont il ya des soldats
prêts à combattre avec des véhicules
blindés donc c'est vraiment une ville
fortifiée dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons on voit que bien bien sûr tout
le monde est très prudent sur qui rentre
dans la ville qui circulent dans la
ville et puis dans l'autre sens un sur
la route entre nikolaev et au dessin
nous avons vu une dizaine de bus remplis
de civils prêt à gagner au dessin et ces
derniers jours bien dans la garde des
sceaux nous avons vu de nombreuses
personnes notamment des femmes des
enfants ou encore des personnes âgées
être prises en charge par des
associations humanitaires avant de
prendre un train pour regagner l'ouest
du pays et on sait que par exemple cette
nuit un nicolas yves a encore été
bombardée sans plus de précision du mois
la banlieue de nicolas yves encore été
bombardée les autorités de la ville nous
disent qu'il ya plusieurs blessés
bonjour julie tant que mikko live n'est
pas tombé julie tant que ce verrou
stratégique n'a pas sauté difficile pour
les russes d'envisager une offensive
d'envergure sur ce qui reste leur
priorité enfin leur objectif cod ça
oui en tout cas c'est ce que beaucoup de
personnes nous ont dit ces derniers
jours à odessa tant que nicolas yves ne
tombera pas eh bien il sera difficile
pour les russes d'envisager et bien une
opération amphibie une opération comme
par la mer comme dans un an vont
beaucoup entendu parler ces derniers
jours cependant est bien difficile de
prévoir ce qui va se passer
ici ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
dans micola yves la communication est
compliquée avec les autorités puisqu'ils
ont subi est bien important bombardement
vendredi où plusieurs dizaines de
soldats ont été tués on ne sait pas
exactement quel est le bilan officiel on
sait qu'une cinquantaine de soldats et
bien sont traités en ce moment à
l'hôpital et plusieurs dizaines serait
mort qu'il ya des funérailles qui auront
lieu aujourd'hui des bombardements je
vous le disais encore eu lieu cette nuit
nous avons également entendu des
bombardements à odessa mais très peu
d'informations filtrent ce que nous 12
10 les autorités ici est bien c'est que
la résistance continue à se faire et que
les troupes ukrainiennes sont parvenus à
repousser l'offensive russe au delà de
la banlieue de la ville et plus vert
carson donc tout le monde espère ici
bien que ils vont continuer à résister
et que par conséquent bien l'offensive
sur rodez ça sera repoussé le plus
longtemps possible